hey at seven ok youtube I need your help
I want to know if I'm full of BS or not
I wrote an email a little while ago
about a team member that I had that I
had to cut back her hours and and the
importance of getting great people on
your team so the summary is you don't
want to accept people on your team who
just get the job done you want to bring
on people who go above and beyond who
love what you're all about and you're
not going to do great work right here
you are not going to do great work with
average people you want to give them
every opportunity to succeed you want to
try as much as you can but not every
person is going to work at your business
anyway I was frustrated I was sad at
that it pained me and I for anybody
who's had to let somebody go you know
what I'm talking about it's one of the
hardest things you have to do in a
business so I want to share that with
you with my audience anyway done my
friend don don writes back Evan I say BS
you made the wrong decision absolutely
the wrong decision fact is there are a
few really great employees out there and
if you are expecting to only hire an
employee really great employees they
will soon see the unfairness in your
approach well done I do agree that there
are really few great employees out there
but great employees for your business
this is the difference you can be a
great employee at one company something
that you believe in and you love what
they stand for and you're going to give
everything you can and you may be a
crappy employees somewhere else the key
is finding people who love what you do
it can also contribute their skills to
you the last part I don't get if you're
expecting only to hire an employee
really great employees they will soon
see the unfairness in your approach
what's the unfairness you think great
people like being around average people
you think somebody who's busting their
ass who is working and giving everything
that got likes being on a team with
somebody who barely cares that that's
unfair bringing in average people on to
your team this guy Don has never done
anything great in his life and
shows because he doesn't understand what
it takes to do something great you have
to build a great team you cannot do this
yourself you need people who love what
they do and who are great at what they
do if you expect to do anything great in
your business that's my take on it
anyway I want to hear what you two think
am I right or is Don right and I'm full
of BS leave a comment below let me know
I'll see you soon